what's up guys i'm dave klein aka dave
control and welcome to another edition
of 10 things you didn't know mixtape
volume 5. at this point i'm going to be
getting into some truly late game
content so you have been warned for
potential spoilers star gazers ruins
if you reach the mountaintops of the
giants and explored you'll probably have
stumbled upon the stargazer's ruins and
this sad jellyfish spirit who just wants
to see the stars with their sister when
they turn 14. tragically you'll find
their gravestones on the cliffside below
that says here lie aurelia and aureliet
who never saw the stars
prepare to cry am i right guys so here's
the thing this is actually a clue to
help you solve the puzzle as to how to
enter the cellar within these ruins if
you talk to roderick at the very
beginning of the game multiple times
before entering stormville castle and
moving forward her quest line she should
have gifted you the spirit jellyfish
ashes read the description and you'll
see prone to tears the jellyfish girl
searches for her distant home it seems
her name is irelia so this is the other
jellyfish spirit ireliet's sister all
you need to do is summon your spirit
jellyfish irelia and you'll reunite the
tragic sisters as well as unlocking the
cellar maybe you'll find the secret of
the titans inside don't mind me i've
been watching attack on titan
market shackle can be used again in
previous videos i've talked about how
you can buy market shackle to use
against margat the first boss of
stormville castle but something you may
not know is even though it's called
market shackle you can actually use the
shackle against morgot the omen king in
lane del
notably just like market you can't use
this during his second phase also i'm
pretty sure you can only use it twice
that said if you need an extra boost
against morgot there you go he is an
omen after all so seems to make sense
the purifying crystal tier
speaking of omens one of the hardest
bosses in the game in my opinion is a
moog lord of blood
no not moog the omen but specifically
the lord of blood you know that guy you
keep hearing about who all of the bloody
fingers follow well there is a pretty
good way to mitigate his difficulty one
of his major major moves against you is
cursing you multiple times then stealing
your life blood as he powers up this
will greatly increase his health for his
much more challenging second phase but
you can stop this entirely with the
flask of wondrous physic it truly is a
wondrous thing what you'll need to do is
find the purifying crystal tier there's
actually two ways to get this and both
involve defeating the bloody finger
eleonora if you've progressed finger
hunter euros questline you can find him
on the altus plateau at the second
church of america and battle eleonora
alternatively you can be invaded by
eleonora near the second church america
even without progressing his quest line
she doesn't always invade and to be
honest i'm not sure what the trigger is
to make it happen but perhaps it's by
visiting the mountaintops of the giants
without having finished this quest line
anyways the important thing is she'll
drop the purifying crystal tear
now check this out the resulting
concoction purifies the curse from moog
lord of blood's terrifying rite of blood
so use this helped nullify his curse
granted i killed moog without using this
so i don't have footage of it but i was
definitely kicking myself later on when
i was re-reading item descriptions
always read item descriptions they
actually matter in this game
the other moog strategy and speaking of
moog lord of blood there's actually not
one but two ways to help mitigate the
difficulty of this fight i'm talking
about shackles although this time we're
not going to be using market shackle but
rather finding a moog shackle moak
shackle can be found in the subterranean
shunning grounds this area is located
underneath lane dell capital city and
can be found by going through the well
located here on a map to find this one
you're going to have to enter the room
with all the pipes going across if you
enter via the shortcut near the
underground roadside site of grace
you'll be at the right area to drop down
now follow the drop down path i show you
in order to reach the bottom you'll be
able to find moog shackle here at the
bottom of the path similar to margaret
shackle you can use this shackle on two
bosses you can use it for moog the omen
within the subterranean shining grounds
and you can use it on moog lord of blood
you can use this twice during his first
phase making it far simpler red main
castle ain't over yet red main castle is
pretty amazing witch hunter gerund is
hosting a celebration of battle that
gives star scourge radon an honorable
death as he's become inflicted with
scarlet rot after his battle with
melania however you might have noticed
there's a bunch of doors in red main
castle you can't open and items
sprinkled around you can't seem to
access
well once you defeat star scourge radon
head back to red main castle and you'll
notice the festival of war is now over
head into the back room you use to
access starskirt's radan and you'll find
witch hunter jaron talk to him and
exhaust his dialogue doing so will turn
red main castle into a normal dungeon
and make all of the various doors now
accessible for opening there's even a
brand new boss in this area defeat this
boss and you'll get the ruins great
sword which is not only needed for an
achievement as it's a legendary armament
but also one of the best colossal sores
as you can get it to have s-tier
strength scaling
distinguishing mausoleums the mausoleums
you can find throughout the lands
between are pretty important as you can
use them to duplicate your boss
remembrances and thereby get more than
one of the boss items
however there are more boss remembrances
than mausoleums so you'll still want to
be careful about which remembrances you
choose to duplicate i duplicated my
godric remembrance early on to test this
mechanic and now i regret it you may
have noticed that not every mausoleum
can seem to duplicate every remembrance
you have and there's actually a way to
tell which will duplicate what
some mausoleums have bells on them and
some of them don't the ones that don't
have bells will only duplicate legendary
remembrances meanwhile the ones that
have bells will duplicate every
remembrance so use this information
wisely and make sure that if you are
going to duplicate a remembrance don't
waste a mausoleum with a bell the secret
of celia
celia town of sorcery has a well hidden
secret within it it's one that you'll be
able to buy a hint about from a merchant
which basically tells you to look at a
cliff by the graveyard however you won't
see anything by doing this the reason
being there's an illusory wall in the
graveyard behind celia town of sorcery
from the church of plague located here
on a map head up north east where you'll
find a distinct sorcerer near a
tombstone behind him and the tombstone
strike the wall and you'll discover it
was an illusory wall the whole time the
location of this luxury wall can be
found here on a map behind is celia
hideaway this location is vital to
sorceress ellen's questline so
definitely keep it in mind two moguin
palace entrances i've talked a lot about
moog lord of blood in this episode but
did you know that there are actually two
ways to access mogwin's palace and the
way to take on moog lord of blood the
first of these is by following vare's
questline i outlined this in an earlier
episode but to state her real quick once
you find him in the rose church he'll
give you festering bloody fingers invade
three people and return to him finish
his questline and he'll gift you the
lord of blood's exaltation if you use
this item you'll be warped right to
mogwin palace and conveniently right
next to its map fragment if you don't
want to invade people have poor internet
or don't want to pay to be able to play
online there is another way to access
this it's located in the mountaintops of
the giants after you access the ground
lifter rolled and find the secret route
to the halo tree you'll be able to
access the lower portion of the mountain
tops now go to this spot on the map on
the western side of the mountaintops
you'll be able to find a warp here that
will take you right to mogwin palace the
hermit village
for whatever reason on my first
playthrough i missed the hermit village
this village is absolutely vital for
starting sorcerer's selling's questline
so i want to detail here how to find it
at mount gelmere you'll find fort lyed
past the seathwater river basically
follow this route up from the map to get
there fort lyde isn't the only thing
you'll find up here though on the
western side of the fort you'll find a
bunch of lava and a magma worm you can
fight it if you want but make sure to
continue traveling west past this magma
worm this route will take you to a
hermit shack and eventually to the
hermit village past the hermit village
you'll have to take on the demi-human
queen maggie once you defeat her you'll
find a sight of grace called primeval
sorcerer's or located here on a map and
you'll be able to find the primeval
sorcerer's or which will kickstar
sorcerer's selling's quest line
exploding concoctions
finally i'm not sure how much you've
played around with your flask of
wondrous physic or if you tried making
an explosive concoction using a ruptured
crystal tear according to his
description it's a defective crystal
tear which possesses absolutely no
medicinal qualities a lesson said to be
learned the hard way for some faith can
be a volatile matter after all it
doesn't sound good but here's what it
does
um
it explodes just like you said it was
going to and hurts you
so what happens if you use both of the
ruptured crystal tears you can find
it causes an even bigger explosion and
hurts you for even more of your health
curiosity did kill the cat indeed the
good news is you can use it on enemies
and it will hurt them for a good amount
as well so maybe it can be a viable
attack option if you want and there you
have 10 more things you may not have
known about eldon ring i hope you
learned at least one new thing here and
i love it if you shared in the comments
findings you guys made as i'm still
learning and discovering new aspects
about the game myself
and i'll see you guys next time peace